Speaker 1: Let's go to Kevin from San Diego.
Kevin, welcome.
What's on your mind?
Speaker 3: Are there, David?
First of all, say, sir, thank you for telling
me to go to Puesto.
Last time I was there, it was incredible.
Really?
Speaker 1: God, did you get the brisket, Taco?
Speaker 3: I did not.
Did you say the brisket taco?
I got the I got the filet mignon tacos.
I got those.
I got the ones with the flame onion and lobster
in them.
And they were I was like the best tacos that
ever had.
Speaker 1: That sounds criminal.
That sounds criminal.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
No, it should be criminalized, honestly.
But anyway.
Okay, on on that.
That's that's a that's a good thing that's
happened.
But unfortunately, we seem to be sliding towards
a bit of a bit of a fascism here.
I'm thinking that, like, do you agree that
it would be.
It would be best if we had like Trump V DeSantis
get really ugly and they I don't know if other
people have talked about this before.
I joined a little late, but.
Speaker 1: Nobody has talked about it other
than me earlier in the week.
I my concern with this entire primary that
is building wherein Trump has announced and
the Santa hasn't but there's polls where he's
already winning to Santos that is my priority
is whatever scenario will get these people
to destroy themselves and each other.
And right now the most likely destructive
path forward is you have a very ugly primary
wherein the Trump and the DeSantis people,
if the Santos runs, hate each other so that
when hopefully DeSantis wins the primary.
And the reason I say that is DeSantis won't
go in run third party, but Trump might.
DeSantis was the primary.
Trump goes and runs third party, takes a bunch
of his supporters because they hate the Santos
and just split the vote and a Democrat easily
wins.
That to me seems like the dream scenario right
now.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I mean, and I think that
Trump was probably aware that that could happen,
but he's still too, like, arrogant, narcissistic
to not do it if he doesn't take the primary
in the first place.
That's my doesn't win.
I don't see any way he he just like lets it
go and doesn't.
Yeah.
He's because he's, he's just, he's just too
crazy to not do that.
Speaker 1: I believe that you are exactly
right.
Which is Trump may be so narcissistic that
even if he intellectually understands or has
people around him saying, you will just hand
this to a Democrat if you run third party,
I hope he does it anyway.
Speaker 3: Right?
Yeah.
But we're getting.
Speaker 1: Ahead of ourselves.
The first question is, does he win the primary?
We're assuming he does.
He still might.
Speaker 3: Yeah, he still might.
And that would be bad.
I just think that, like, there's enough things
where the Republicans are, like, kind of even
if even not counting the current primary.
There's like the the Supreme Court, the movie
Harper.
I don't remember exactly which the one that
was that that's deciding things so that the
states can make their own things with no federal,
their own election rules, with no federal
oversight.
Indeed.
Which if that is decided by the court in favor
of like the what the Republicans want, I feel
like there's a bunch of states that are just
going to be like, oh, yes, the Republicans
won again no matter what.
Basically, they're going to make rules to
to not necessarily to, you know, decide elections
against what people actually voted, but essentially
suppress enough of the vote and make it to
only the places that they know we're going
to be voting for.
Republicans are going to count essentially
Indiana.
And then they'll they'll never be won by anyone
anywhere close to progressive again.
Speaker 1: That is a horrible of we were it's
horrible what you're saying but it's a few
steps ahead.
So let's reserve judgment and see what happens
next, if that makes sense here.
Speaker 3: Oh, it's not bad to think about
it just to plan ahead.
Speaker 1: I'm with you.
I'm with you.
But
I
appreciate
the call.
Speaker 3: Yeah, it's nice talking.
You all.
Speaker 1: Right?
There is Kevin from San Diego